il va d'amélioration la parole et à
monsieur olivier dassault merci monsieur
le président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre la semaine
dernière alors qu'il tentait de
justifier son remaniement ministériel le
président de la république a soutenu
l'idée d' une flexisécurité à la
française pour vaincre le chômage
alors si je me réjouis que cette notion
est enfin convaincu votre majorité
permettez moi de soulever quelques
inquiétudes sur la terminologie à la
française si célèbre la france pour ses
35 heures pour sa taxe 75%
vous savez en amour comme en politique
tout est une question de confiance
il faut l'avouer il n'est pas au beau
fixe dans le couple et à entreprises
parce que les règles imposées par la
décourage l'investissement de l'autre ce
sera un mariage vouée à l'échec une
séparation programmé un divorce pour
faute grave
si l'état ne fait pas l'effort de
renoncer avec de renouer plus tôt avec
la compétition
je vous propose de cesser cette lutte
contre l'emploi et de faire comme nos
voisins de combattre le chômage
vous parlez de flexibilité à l'embauché
pour les entreprises je ne vois que des
taxes que des charges qui continuent de
proliférer libérer la capacité
d'entreprendre en diminuant les impôts
sur le travail et sur le capital au lieu
de promettre un chèque de 2000 euros aux
entreprises pour les inciter à embaucher
plutôt que de donner arrêtez de prendre
quand vous parlez dans bocian artisans
et nous répond là là c'est trop risqué
parce qu'il a vécu une séparation
difficile et si vous féliciter cette
séparation
eh bien vous faciliterez également les
embauches c'est cela la vraie
flexisécurité comme au danemark
et comme en espagne plus récemment je
regrette monsieur le premier ministre
que la véritable exception à la
française ne soit que nos sept cent
mille chômeurs de plus depuis l'élection
présidentielle au moment où les états
unis renouent avec le plein emploi alors
rappelez vous monsieur le premier
ministre
notre avenir les armées raison de notre
deschamps j'adore les dames myriam el
khomri ministre du travail de l'emploi
et de la formation
jamel et du dialogue social merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député olivier dassault le
président de la république la semaine
dernière a dit qu'entre ce qu'ils ne
veulent rien faire ce qu'ils veulent
tout défaire nous nous voulons bien
faire et il y a une cohérence dans
l'action de ce gouvernement depuis 2012
cette cohérence
nous venons en parlait à l'instant le
pack de responsabilité le cic eux si ce
n'est pas une preuve d'amour en
direction des entreprises dites moi
qu'est ce que c'est cela permet en effet
aux entreprises de retrouver des marges
il ya des engagements réciproques qui
devront être tenus mais depuis 2012
embêté hotz est la même c'est celle qui
est faite par le dialogue par la
négociation
vous pensez que c'est une perte de temps
vous vous êtes pour l'univers terral de
l'employeur c'est ça que vous appelez le
lait pour vous c'est la flexibilité sans
sécurité
voilà la réalité c'est le contournement
organisations syndicales
ce n'est absolument pas notre
philosophie notre philosophie à nous
c'est justement de laisser plus de place
à la négociation collective plus de
capacité plus de souplesse bien sûr aux
entreprises mais ceci par la négociation
et depuis 2012 nous avons fait du chemin
en la matière négocier pour anticiper
négocier pour éviter des licenciements
et quand on ne peut pas faire autrement
négocier aussi pour permettre un
meilleur reclassement des salariés est
derrière tout cela
qu'est ce qu'il y a eu moins de ps - de
contentieux et plus d'accord qui sont
négociés et des droits nouveaux qui ont
été mis en place
la complémentaire santé le compte
personnel de formation c'est d'autres
cet esprit justement je travaille mal
loi cette loi elle vise à laisser plus
d'espacé à la négociation plus de
capacités au niveau des accords
d'entreprise justement parce que la loi
ne pourra pas tout régler et entre la
posture des organisations patronales
parfois qu'ils veulent bien négocier
mais sans les syndicats
la potion certaines organisations
syndicales qui veulent absolument aucun
objet de négociation et la posture
parfois des pouvoirs publics qui est de
tout réglementer cette nouvelle
philosophie que nous voulons impulser et
qui sera dans la loi que je porterai
aubry dans son slim